hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and on this video
i'm going to be answering your property
investment questions so any questions
that you have that have been niggling
you or annoying you that are stopping
you you getting to the next level in
property
why don't you just ask away and i will
do my very best to answer your property
investment questions to help you get to
the next level in property also if you
enjoy my videos please give me a massive
favor
hit the like button and also subscribe
for more videos so last week i had a
whole bunch of questions
from you guys uh jessica
said
thank you so much for your video sam
your question i'm going to begin deal
sourcing in the coming weeks good for
you
in what order
do you need to send the nda
receive the sources fee
and send the due diligence documents
once you've found a deal thank you and
god bless
so if you're gonna send an ndi you would
pretty much do it um well if you okay so
you're gonna send an nda non-disclosure
agreement that's gonna mean that the
investor when you give them and you
reveal them the full address and the
details they can't cut you out so you're
going to send them the nda
they're going to sign it and send it you
back then you're going to send them all
of the details the address the due
diligence everything over for them to
take a look at and then if they're happy
and they want to go ahead they're then
going to pay the finders fee along with
sign your contracts and your terms and
conditions that's that's generally the
order but it can depend sometimes
they'll pay you upfront with no nda
without knowing any details just
headlines and then you'll give them a
calling off period and then you'll then
give them the details of the property
and they'll have a calling off period um
whereby if they don't like the property
you you have to refund the deal hope
that helps
ben field house
been watching your videos for years i
still never started in property come on
ben what's happening um how do i find
people who are already in property that
i can learn off so
you want three type tons of people in
your life you want success buddies
success buddies are people that you can
bounce ideas off that you can cheer each
other on you're probably best to find
these people maybe at training programs
at networking events online on facebook
groups you also want a mentor you want
somebody that can tell you what to do um
and then lastly is you want somebody
that you can help and you can be a role
model too as well and where do you find
them um well why don't you come down to
one of my courses and you can meet me
maybe i can be your mentor and then you
can meet hundreds of other students that
could be your success buddies take
action uh stop watching videos on
youtube and start actually going out and
meeting people all right next
show
i probably pronounced that wrong i
apologize what's the best way to get a
letting agent on your side when trying
to secure a rent to rent deal any advice
would be appreciated so whenever you're
doing business with anybody you need to
think what's in it for them
so why would they benefit from doing
business with you so if it's a latin
agent i would just be thinking hang on
they've got landlords that have got
properties they want to get them rented
i am a corporate company offering
guaranteed rent to landlords how's the
letting agent going to benefit well
maybe they're going to get their finders
fee
if they want to charge a monthly
management fee maybe they could still do
that and almost get a passive income
just for finding me so think of all the
reasons what's going to benefit the
agent what's going to benefit the
landlord and then put your deal forward
um accordingly
all right next
manlik a cac
samuel your character and approach to
releasing financial freedom education
has been amazing and very appreciated
what's the best long-term and financial
way to start property investment into
property as a working 18 year old to the
brr method or if you wanted to do buy
refurbished refinance rent buy a house
add value and you're 18. first thing i
want to say is i did my first deal at 17
and it was basically a brr deal i bought
it below market value then i refinanced
it pulled the money back out how on
earth did i do it i had didn't have the
finance i didn't have the credit i don't
have anything but i had the knowledge to
find the deals
so if you wanted to get into brr what i
would say start finding vrr deals start
finding deals the person that finds the
most deals and the best deals is the
person that will win because even if you
can't buy the property because you're oh
man i don't really got the credit i've
really got then find it and sell it to
somebody and gain from the experience
uh offer a project management fee and
then once you've got a bit of experience
and you can demonstrate that you've done
it then the next deal that you find get
an investor to become a joint venture
partner and then join venture your way
to being a millionaire by age 21. boom
it's possible lots of people have done
it
don juvie what are the one to three of
your best tips for conducting market
research for rent to serviced
accommodation how can i gauge the demand
for corporate let's different areas so
one to three best tips for conducting
market research for rent service
accommodation number one is you want to
find out how much
your rooms are going to rent out for or
how much the property is going to go
rent for on a nightly basis
and how you're gonna know that i would
say number one tip is look at what the
hotels are doing
find all the hotels within a mile and if
there's no hotels within a mile
maybe there's a reason that there's no
one that's bought a hotel in the area
maybe no one wants to rent short-term
lets no one wants short-term stays so if
there's hotels in the area i think
that's a good sign um in the ask the
hotels hey have you got five rooms
tonight anything else no
we're fully booked
boom that's a good sign if we go yeah
man we got five rooms tonight
bad sign also look on airbnb and see
your competitors rooms and your
competitors stays and their properties
and you can look at their calendars and
see how books up they are and see
um
how much they're charging
and the third tip would be to find
another
entrepreneur that's doing rent service
accommodation in the area and ask them
hey how's it going what what tips have
you got for me most people in this
industry want to see other people win as
well generally speaking hope that helps
gus i've always watched your videos and
never asked a question ah first question
amazing listen if you never asked a
question go ahead and ask your first
question today i would really like to
have a one-to-one with you currently
have a buy to let i would like to
remortgage but i'm seriously concerned
about my credit rating which would be a
possible obstacle i need help by the way
i love your videos thank you so much
tola um our best thing to do is to go on
to credit karma or experian and find out
what your credit rating is if it's bad
fix it
if your credit rating is bad it's bad
for a reason now sometimes you can't fix
it maybe if you've got like if you've
been bankrupt or if you've got a county
court judgment or something but even if
you've got a county court judgment it
might be that you can set it up and get
that removed um or if you've got you
know bad credit because you are uh you
missed the payment to ee and now you've
dented your credit ring them up get it
off
pay pay it get it finish it maybe you're
not on the electoral roll if you're not
on the electoral roll then it's gonna
affect your credit right now uh
sometimes it might just be they have to
wait a little bit um for your credit
ready to sort yourself out but actively
be looking at what your credit rating is
once a month getting it better um and
also and then when you know what your
credit rating is and you've got it as
good as you can get it even if it's only
fair
if it's not good if it's just fair or
speak to a mortgage broker and say this
is my credit report what can you do for
me and you'll be surprised
mac
do you think getting into property
management to start with would be worth
it if so how could i go about by
starting this yeah i think it's great
that's what i did i used to manage
properties rent rooms out um and just to
give me experience to build friends it's
a great idea
how to get started find and connect with
landlords become friends with landlords
anthony thomas what do you recommend i
do i have money
roughly 60 to 70 grand i've been offered
a mortgage of 300 grand with a 10 put
down and i have no kids i'm single no
ties what do you i want to get in
property i'm interested in brr but do
you think this is a good place to start
um yeah listen if you're getting into
bro i doubt you're going to be able to
put down just 10 because
um i mean 10 maybe if you're gonna buy a
house to live in it
but i wouldn't recommend doing that i
wouldn't get a residential mortgage i
would use you 60 to 70 grand rather than
getting a 300 grand mortgage that's
probably a residential mortgage i would
use your 60 to 70 grand i would buy a
little cheap house in cash and then get
development finance not a mortgage to do
it up
and then get a mortgage and refinance it
pull your money out i wouldn't be
getting a house to live in no way all
right last question sam hawkins
when refinancing on the new value of a
property how soon can you release the
equity created to be used again
does this get released straight away on
the new buy to let mortgage or do you
have to wait a minimum amount of time
great question so um so it depends
there's a few things there's three
different scenarios so if you bought a
property with a mortgage
so if you buy a house with a residential
mortgage or with a buy to let mortgage
or any kind of mortgage
generally speaking
there is gonna the mortgage company are
gonna give you that money but they're
gonna say you can't pay it back for a
minimum of two years maybe three years
okay sometimes one but two is quite
standard
so if you want to refinance it and get a
new mortgage
once the value has been added
you're gonna have to either wait two
years
which is a pain or you're gonna have to
pay
early repayment charges which might be a
few thousand pounds so that's scenario
one scenario two
is that you buy the property for cash or
you buy it with a bridging loan the
definition of a bridging loan is to
bridge the gap
between the purchase and the new
mortgage now if you do that generally
speaking you're going to have to wait
six months because even if you buy a
property for cash
most lenders will say we'll let you
refinance
once you've owned it for six months
however owning a property for six months
before you refinance it is standard and
no problem because it's gonna take you a
few months to do the refurb anyway so
that's the usual option but option
number three there are some lenders that
will let you refinance straight away
such as kent reliance such as precise
mortgages so you can buy a property with
a bridging loan or cash or angel
investment or whatever private finance
and you can buy it
you can do it up
and you can refinance
straight away i.e like two weeks later
no problem but there's only a few
lenders that will let you do that and
your rates might not be as preferable if
you decided to wait six months
i've done this so many times you can
probably tell and if you enjoy my videos
and if you enjoy my content please do me
a favor hit the like button ask more
questions below and i will comment i
will help you i will answer because i
really believe that if you're going to
be successful in property you may as
well bring other people up with you my
name's samuel leeds and i'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
you